من وسط جموع اليمنيين المتطرفين خرج اثمار
بنج فيل يتولى ما كان يبتغي في الحكومه
الاسرائيليه وزاره الامن الداخلي
اتفاق الائتلاف بين حزب اليكود وحزب
العظمه اليهوديه الذي راسه بنغفيره ليمهد
ذلك الطريقه لحكومه نتنياهو من اجل ان
ترنر وزاره الامن الداخلي في اسرائيل هي
هيئه اركان المشتركه بقرار من الحكومه تم
تغيير اسمها عام
1995 بعد ما كان وزاره الشرطه
وهي المسؤوله عن تطبيق القانون والحفاظ
على النظام العام وكل ما يتعلق بالامن
الداخلي حيث تعمل عبر اجهزه مختلفه هي
شرطه اسرائيل ومصلحه السجون وسلطه حمايه
الشهود وسلطه مكافحه المخدرات والكحول
لكننا نتنياهو يريدها بصلاحيات اوسع فقد
اضاف اليها اداره شرطه حرس الحدود في
الضفه الغربيه المحتله
نالت هذه صلاحيات رضا بني كثير الذي علق
على اتفاقه مع اللي كود قائلا ان حزبه حصل
على الادوات اللازمه لاعاده الامن
للاسرائيليين والاهتمام بالسكان في الجليل
والنقب والضواحي لكن اتفاق بكثير نتنياهو
لم يلقى ترحيب لدى وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
الذي قال ان الفكره من وراء ما جرى لاتفاق
عليه بينهما هي خلق جيش خاص لبني كثير في
الضفه الغربيه على نحو يشكل خطوره على
تفعيل قوات الجيش ويخلق مشاكل امنيه
حقيقيه وصفها بانها اشبه بعمليه ارهابيه
ومثل ذلك تخشى السلطه الفلسطينيه فحسب
بيان لوزاره الخارجيتها فان صلاحيات التي
يمنحها نتنياهو لبن كفيره ستكون لها
انعكاسات على اي جهود اقليميه ودوليه تبذل
من اجل التهدئه
[موسيقى]
الاتفاق المثير للجدل بين اللكود وحزب
العظمه اليهوديه يمنح حزب بن كثير ايضا
رئاسه لجنه الامن الداخلي بالكنيست ومنصب
نائب وزير الاقتصاد وتضمنا ايضا تسويه
الوضع القانوني ل 65 بؤره عشوائيه في
الضفه الغربيه
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه بشكل قد يكون غير
مسبوقه فيثمار بن كثير نفسه عام 2007
بالتحديد العنصري ضد العرب ودعم جماعه
تعتبرها الولايات المتحده منظمه ارهابيه
لقد كان الرجل معارضا بشراسه لاقامه دوله
فلسطينيه وشهد خلال الحمله ادعائيه
للانتخابات وهو يلوح ببندقيه في اتجاه
متظاهرين فلسطين في القدس الشرقيه